many undergraduate students learn about
writing in University the hard way and
only a very small percentage of them
ever receive an A on their written
assignments and the reason they can't
achieve top marks in university is their
High School teachers but the real
tragedy isn't the low grades it's the
Miss opportunity to discover the
life-changing benefits of academic
writing because the fact is that writing
in university is nothing like writing in
high school and to show you the
difference between high school and
University Writing I need to go back to
when I was in high school
when hey shut up so when I was in grade
school I received a lot of encouragement
about my writing I would love writing
stories and sharing them with friends
and by the time I got to high school I
even had my own column in the local
newspaper so when I came to University I
was pretty confident and self assured
about my writing abilities writing was a
breeze I'll never forget the first essay
that I got back in University it was
actually in an English literature class
and somewhere along the way I must have
introduced an idea with the phrase I
think and the comment that I got back
from my professor in the margins said
who are you I I was so offended who are
you I'm William this is what I think
here's my opinion this is gold Pearls
Before Swine I really couldn't
understand the comment but instead of
getting mad at my professor I took some
time and realized that that there was
something about writing in University
that I didn't understand so for my next
paper I did what I encourage all
undergraduate students to do ideally
before you write your first paper which
is to make an appointment with the
University Writing Center the University
where I teach has a Writing Center and
the one you're attending probably does
as well this is a place where you can
have a consultation with a writing tutor
who can help you develop your paper and
point out some of these things before it
makes it to your professor's desk and I
really wish I had done that sooner but
once I started working with these
writing tutors I came to understand what
this professor was looking for it wasn't
my spelling it wasn't my grammar these
professors weren't asking me to write
something better they wanted me to write
something different and that's when I
realized that as good as I had done in
high school I was totally unprepared for
writing in University now you might know
the following expression if someone asks
you what time is don't tell them how to
build a watch well when it comes to
academic writing the opposite is true
now that doesn't mean your professors
are asking you to write more than
necessary in fact University professors
will often tell you to not go over two
pages or five pages as the assignment
may be but this expression just means
that when it comes to academic writing
there is a different task there's
something different we have to do so
imagine your high school teacher had
given you an assignment to write an
essay about a watch how would you begin
that essay well if you were in high
school you might have one paragraph
about how this is the minute hand it
represents the minutes and then there's
the dial over here and that's how you
get it going and the numbers on the
watch range from 1 to 12 you might have
a paragraph explaining each of those
ideas and the crazy thing is that kind
of writing would pass because in high
school we write for the sake of writing
High School teachers give us feedback
about spelling organization vocabulary
it doesn't matter what we write so long
as we write it well but in University
that kind of response wouldn't work
because the task of writing is
completely different it's not enough to
just summarize all the parts in fact
unless the writing assignment
specifically uses the word summary what
your University professors are looking
for is not a summary but an analysis in
other words don't just say what
something is right about how it works
another word for that kind of analysis
is argument in University writings we
have arguments Now by argument I don't
just mean a verbal fight with a friend
about what's better or worse instead an
argument is something much more
systematic and it's the kind of thing
that careful readers expect of you
especially in an academic context now
before I show you how to write an
argument you might be wondering why
should I have to write an argument at
all I know what I think think aren't my
points valid on their own to understand
why that's not the case in University
let's turn out the
lights now here's a flashlight what do
you see from where you're standing you
see this part but me standing over here
with my own flashlight I see that part
we each have only partial knowledge and
so it's important that we share our
ideas with each other so that we can get
a view of the bigger picture and the way
that we share those ideas with each
other are arguments why arguments why
couldn't I just publish an essay that
says exactly what I see why go through
the trouble of putting my ideas into
this thing called an argument so I teach
at a Science and Tech Research Institute
so I'm used to working with scientists
and engineers and whenever I'm
explaining this point I usually like to
draw their attention to the scientific
method so I'll ask students like why do
we publish research why do we go through
the trouble of writing up research and
Publishing it in journals and actually
what they'll often say at the beginning
is that we do it in order to get
Prestige and and get um to advance our
career and to be honest partially
they're right but that's not the whole
story ideally the reason that we publish
our research in these scientific
journals is to invite others to critique
our research that's how we advance as a
collective I do my best with my
scientific research and I publish it and
then everybody tries to attack me to
take me down and and that's a healthy
thing it's really stressful when it's
happening but other people argue with my
research and show how I did a bad job
and they try to break it apart as much
as possible but anything they can't
break apart anything that remains after
everybody attacks it that part is solid
and that's the part that everybody has
to accept now as scientific knowledge
it's just considered true if nobody can
break the ideas apart if nobody can
break my research and findings apart
then it's now true and the community has
to accept it as true so that's the
reason that we share our ideas in the
form of an argument but the thing is you
can't answer all questions with the
scientific method in the hard Sciences
we can design experiments to tell us
what the world is like but there are
other questions that we can't answer
using a science experiment such as what
is good or bad what is the meaning of
art which one is better or worse these
are things that cannot be answered in a
science lab so the reason that we write
our ideas in the form of these arguments
is to invite other people to disagree
with us they're going to attack our
ideas and an argument is what shows
other people not only what we think but
why we think it in other words the
evidence and the reasoning that we use
to develop our opinions so this idea of
critique and peer review that we know in
the scientific method well it's the same
thing in our academic essays it's just
that there are some questions that you
can answer with scientific experiments
and other questions which you can't and
we can only develop them through
arguments so we write in the form of
arguments to invite other people to
fight with us so that together we can
find out what's true okay so now we know
that your professor is different from
your high school teacher because your
professor wants you to write an argument
so how do you write one well basically
an argument has three crucial pieces
a claim a truth claim in other words
it's saying that something is true now
ideally that something is going to make
the reader say hm that's interesting I'd
like to know more if the reader can't
say that to your claim you don't have a
claim so for example the statement water
is wet the reader is not going to read
that and say hm that's interesting I'd
like to know more like it's just true
you don't need evidence to support it
you don't need to show your reasoning
the reader doesn't need to spend energy
reading what you've written it's not
worth anything it's not a claim a claim
should be significant it should develop
our understanding of the topic and of
course it should be nonobvious which
means that the reader is going to want
to see how you arrived at that claim
what's your evidence what's your
reasoning and finally it should be
debatable it should be something that
somebody else could disagree with so
that's how you know you have a good
claim it should be significant not
obvious and debatable so those are the
three features of a claim and if you
make an interesting non-obvious claim
it's going to have to be backed up by
evidence otherwise the reader won't
accept it and so if our definition of a
claim is something that somebody else
can disagree with then the next thing
the reader is going to want to see is
have you thought about the limitations
and objections to your claim what are
the counterarguments somewhere out there
there are people who disagree with you
so before you just move on from your own
claim why don't you spend a little bit
of time thinking about what are those
people going to say and respond to those
people you would say something like of
course my critics would argue X but what
they fail to understand is a b and c and
so therefore my claim is still correct
and this actually becomes a big critique
of University Writing because a lot of
people say that one of the worst things
about academic writing is that it's so
filled with all of these qualifiers
these Hedges people don't say water is
wet they say something like it seems as
though water could most probably be wet
under these circumstances right they
qualify everything to bring their level
of certainty down from 100% to 70 60 50%
depending on the strength of their claim
and and yeah it doesn't make the best
reading experience and it's kind of weak
but again the reason that they do this
is because writing in university is
necessarily
argumentative if you make a claim and
it's too strong you haven't thought
about the limitations of your claim you
haven't thought about what people who
disagree with you are going to say then
people are going to get they're they're
either going to reject what you've
written or they're going to get really
and attack your writing so careful
writers in University consider the
strength of their claims and they make
sure to adjust it appropriately using
Hedges such as sometimes usually
generally or when appropriate they'll
use boosters such as absolutely strongly
certainly so importantly you want to
bring your writing into conversation
with others address your critics and
show that you've thought carefully about
the strength of your claim so if you've
taken one thing from this video I really
hope that it is writing in University
sure it is different and your professors
are making different demands on you but
these are good demands you should be
really excited about this opportunity no
longer is writing just a matter of using
perfect grammar and spelling suddenly
you're doing important intellectual work
writing is not writing writing is
thinking in high school we write about
what we already already know but in
University we write to discover ideas
and then to share those discoveries with
a community of people who are just like
us people who are committed to finding
the truth together we write about these
discoveries in the form of an argument
so that others can test our discoveries
try to break them apart and if they
can't break it apart then they must
accept our discoveries as new knowledge
now that you know the major differences
between high school and University
writing you probably want to get started
in writing your own academic report
which is why you need to check out this
video right here because it's going to
show you exactly how to get started with
an academic report so be sure to go
check it
out